[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: As you deploy
workloads in Google Cloud,
you need centralized visibility
into the security posture
and status of your environment.
You need a way to
surface vulnerabilities
and malicious activity
with clear ways
to take action against them.
Security Command Center is a
built-in security management
tool for Google
Cloud Platform that
helps you prevent, detect,
and remediate vulnerabilities
and threats.
You can identify misconfigured
virtual machines, containers,
networks, storage, and identity
and access management policies,
as well as web application
vulnerabilities,
and act on them before
they damage your business.
With Security
Command Center, you
can perform several
security-related actions
from a single
centralized dashboard.
Let's get started by
completing three steps.
Step one, set up
Cloud IAM permissions.
To get started,
you need to ensure
you have the correct
permissions set up in Cloud IAM.
These roles can be enabled
from the GCP console
IAM and admin page.
To view the Security
Command Center,
you must have the Security
Center Admin Viewer role.
To make changes, you must have
an appropriate editor role,
like Security
Center Admin Editor.
To set up Security
Command Center
for the first time
for your organization,
you'll need five roles--
Organization Admin,
Security Center Admin,
Security Center Settings
Admin, Security Admin,
and Service Account Creator.
Step two, choose services.
Head to the console.
On the left-hand panel,
navigate to Security
and then click Security
Command Center.
On the Organization dropdown
list, select your organization.
Note-- if this is the first
time your organization is using
Security Command
Center, you will
be directed through
a sign-up flow, where
you will choose your services.
For organizations
that have already
completed the sign-up flow,
you may review and refine
your services from the UI.
To do so, click on Add Security
Sources to review and enable
the services that
Security Command
Center will use to
show you the security
state of your resources.
Our built-in services are
Security Health Analytics,
which can identify misconfigured
virtual machines, containers,
networks, storage, and identity
and access management policies.
The built-in capabilities
in the standard tier
include scans for high-severity
misconfigurations,
such as open storage buckets.
When using Security Health
Analytics in the premium tier,
you get scans for broader
security misconfigurations,
such as API keys
needing to be rotated.
In addition, you get compliance
monitoring and security posture
management against PCI DSS, CIS
GCP 1.0, NIST 800-53, and ISO
27001 recommendations, among
other security best practices.
For premium users, there are
additional services available.
Web Security Scanner
manage scan capabilities,
which automatically detect
new public-facing web
applications deployed
on Google Cloud
and can detect vulnerabilities
in those applications,
including those from
categories in the OWASP top 10,
such as cross-site scripting,
use of clear text passwords,
and outdated libraries.
Event Threat Detection,
which uses log data
from inside your systems and
watches your organization's
Cloud Logging stream to detect
threats like brute-force SSH,
Cloud IAM abuse, malware,
and data exfiltration.
Container Threat
Detection, which
can detect some of the
most common threats seen
in the containerized
workloads running on GKE,
such as adversaries dialing
home with reverse shells
or the execution of
binaries in libraries
that did not come from
your secure build pipeline.
You can also integrate
with other services
to have their findings surfaced
in Security Command Center.
Cloud Armor, which is
a customizable service
for protecting applications
from DDoS or web attacks.
Cloud Armor sends
any allowed traffic
spike and increasing deny ratio
findings to Security Command
Center.
Data Loss Prevention, which
shows storage buckets that
contain sensitive
and regulated data,
integrates and
surfaces its findings
into Security Command Center.
And partner solutions
from many partners,
such as Chef
Automate, which can be
integrated into Security
Command Center and enabled here.
You can enable or
disable a service
by clicking the toggle
next to the service name.
The services will be enabled
at the organization level.
Optionally, you can enable
or disable your services
for individual resources by
navigating to the Resources
tab.
Click the dropdown list
in the Service column
to select service
enablement on a resource.
Now Security Command Center
is ready to help you prevent,
detect, and respond to threats.
This leads up to step number
three, view your dashboards.
Security Command Center gives
you a lot of flexibility
to review the security
state of your resources.
Explore contains a directory
of the dashboards, displays,
and services available to you.
On the Threats
dashboard, you can
review potentially harmful
events in your organization's
resources.
These events are summarized
by severity, category,
and resource or project.
The Threats dashboard displays
results for the time period
you specify in
the dropdown list.
Click through these
items to see more detail
on the specific findings.
The Vulnerabilities dashboard
display Security Health
Analytics findings
and recommendations.
The findings can be filtered
to one or more projects
and also by other
characteristics,
such as categories,
severity, and/or benchmarks.
The Recommendations
column provides
a summary of how to
remediate the finding.
More details on the finding can
be viewed by clicking through.
The Compliance dashboard uses
Security Health Analytics
and Web Security
Scanner detectors
to monitor for violations
against common compliance
controls, which are part of
various industry regimes,
including CIS and PCI.
While not a replacement
for a compliance audit,
it can be used to
help you maintain
your continuous compliance
and catch violations early.
You can filter by
project and view
or export reports of specific
findings by compliance regime.
If you'd like to export Security
Command Center data, including
assets and findings, you
can find the Export button
on the Assets or Finding
tabs on the dashboard.
You can also have event threat
detection and container threat
detection findings automatically
logged to Cloud Logging.
To enable, navigate
to Settings and click
on the Sinks tab, where you
can turn on the service.
Congratulations.
That's it.
You're set up to start using
Security Command Center.
[MUSIC PLAYING]